if this is how you picture walking on
Uranus you're
wrong let's start this
again are you ready to take a trip to
the outer regions of the solar system to
explore the weirdest planet in our
Cosmic
neighborhood to venture down into a
place that's never been studied up close
by any
spacecraft buckle up for an icy violent
and stinky Adventure because your
mission is to spend 5 seconds on
Uranus and come
back if you
can traveling to Uranus would be a long
strange Journey first you'd have to
spend 10 long years in a spaceship
speeding toward the outskirts of the
solar system if you're lucky you might
even pass Jupiter and Saturn on the way
just make sure you pack enough food and
fuel well there are some things you
should know about this world Uranus
isn't a rocky planet like Earth it's an
ice giant like Neptune and it's the only
planet in the solar system that spins on
its side it spins fast too one day on
Uranus is just 17 Earth hours of course
you wouldn't last that long on it not a
chance once you arrived at your
destination you still have some work to
do to get close to this giant blue
planet you might have to dodge Uranian
Rings yeah Uranus has rings 13 of them
they aren't big and Majestic like the
gorgeous rings of Saturn the outer rings
are bright and easy to spot but the
inner rings are narrow and dark you'd
have to navigate this part of the trip
with the utmost
care as you made your way through the
dusty rings of Uranus you'd see its
glorious blue atmosphere up close for
the first time in human history take a
moment to enjoy the ah
Uranus what an odd balls Planet you know
I flew by it a month ago that was fun
you want to know why no body and I mean
nobody has ever tried to land anything
on the surface of this bootyful planet
because Uranus has no surface it's just
a swirling ball of toxic gas compressed
around a small icy core oh and wait till
I tell you why those gases on Uranus are
toxic
yeah gross yeah okay thanks for your
input Chase it's true Uranus might have
a calming blue color but it's cold and
toxic not the kind of blue planet you
want to
visit that's okay I think you should sit
this one out here I go
[Music]
woohoo H it's brisk here oh Rico what's
the temperature - 224° c oh that's cold
that explains why feel my fingers or my
toes or the rest of my body okay well at
least those 5 seconds are done okay Rico
it's time to go home let's bounce
impossible if my calculations are
correct you will reach the icy core in
54.4 minutes so what that wasn't the
plan what's point4 of a minute you
seconds you dumb bot I suggest you take
this opportunity to study the planet up
close and report back well I suggest you
take this opportunity and stuffing up
your charging port I don't have a
charging port no one cares
Rico no one cares honestly this sucks
Uranus smells
like yeah the reason Uranus smells so
bad is that the clouds in its upper
atmosphere are partially made up of
hydrogen
sulfide not only does this make the
planet stink but it's also pretty
toxic whatever you do do not inhale it
if you did it' make you faint and die
instantly what would have been real nice
to know this before I jumped yeah well
after falling through the stinky clouds
at the top atmosphere you'd find
yourself in the mix of 82% hydrogen 15%
helium and a bit of
methane methane gas is what gives Uranus
that bluish green Haze because it
absorbs light at the red end of the
spectrum
huh these uh these clouds are getting a
little weird kind of
floaty yeah the atmosphere on Uranus is
very dense after passing through its top
layer you'd stop falling and start
swimming in it instead as you were
paddling deeper you'd start getting
pelted by Frozen gas
crystals but at least the temperature
would be rising I don't know about that
I don't feel warm at all oh Rico give me
the stats the temperature around you has
indeed gone up to - 208° c my
calculations show you can expectus
153° C in the lower atmosphere cool
great ow what is that that well that's
Diamond rain yeah on urinous it rains
diamonds that's because the Uranian
atmosphere is rich in methane a single
carbon compound under extreme pressure
the methane molecules break apart and
crystallize into diamonds but the worst
part is the wind you'd be dealing with
winds gusting at speeds of up to 900
kmph that's 3 and 1/2 times stronger
than a category 5 hurricane here on
Earth R it's getting tighten here oh I
can hardly breathe and when I do breathe
it smells like ass of of course the
pressure is 100 times greater than the
atmospheric pressure at Earth's sea
level you are approaching the
mantle the good news is you wouldn't
splatter on anything because there's not
much in the way of solids on Uranus the
Uranian mantle is made of water ammonia
and methane ice it would be Pitch Black
in here and thanks to the extreme
gravity you wouldn't be able to move a
muscle and it would still be incredibly
cold
what you should be worried about is the
immense pressure that would be rapidly
increasing the closer you got to the
planet center it would squish you before
you ever got to the
core being crushed by Uranus I always
thought it would be way
nicer well in this extreme pressure
environment your carbon-based body could
turn into diamonds and drop down into
the core what a spectacular way to
finish this oneway trip to the center of
Uranus Chase oh all
right our solar system is enormous there
are so many planets and moons that are a
lot more hospitable for a 5sec mission
than
Uranus where should you go next how
about a place covered in methane lakes
and with a fantastic view of Saturn in
the
sky well that's a story for
another what
[Music]
if